continuamos ahora con nuestro especial
de noticias sobre la posición del nuevo
presidente de costa rica rodrigo chávez
ya lo decíamos el nuevo jefe de estado
fue elegido en una segunda vuelta el
pasado 3 de abril
allí se enfrentó al ex presidente josé
maría figueres y logró un 52,8 por
ciento de los votos costa rica sigue
siendo considerada una de las
democracias más estables de la región y
es un ejemplo para américa latina en
varios sectores no obstante hay índices
sociales y económicos que en los últimos
años han generado una especie de
retroceso a esta hora continuamos viendo
las imágenes que nos llegan en vivo
desde la sede de la asamblea nacional
donde se realiza el traspaso de poder
carlos alvarado le entrega el poder a
rodrigo chávez que será presidente de
este país hasta
2026 para analizar la llegada del
mandatario a la casa presidencial y los
retos que le esperan en estos cuatro
años nos acompaña en el estudio manuel
es el es magíster en ciencia política de
la universidad de salamanca y vía skype
nancy hernández politóloga costarricense
y alejandro molina ramírez politólogo
del observatorio de la política nacional
de la universidad de costa rica a los
tres les doy la bienvenida a france 24
en principio conozcamos quien es rodrigo
chávez una figura popular dentro del
país pero que no está exento de polémica
tras ser sancionado por acoso sexual
cuando trabajaba para el banco mundial
alva santana tiene los detalles
economista de profesión y natural del
distrito del carmen en costa rica
rodrigo chávez obtuvo un doctorado
económico en la universidad de ohio lo
que le abrió las puertas al banco
mundial donde trabajó durante más de 25
años
en 2019 el político renunció a su cargo
y volvió a costa rica comenzó su carrera
política al ser fichado para ocupar el
ministerio de hacienda puesto que
desempeñó durante 184 días y del que
también terminó renunciando no fue hasta
2021 cuando anunció que se unía al
partido social democrático desde donde
ha defendido políticas conservadoras con
un discurso nacionalista a favor de la
recuperación económica del país a través
de pactos con organismos como el fm el
actual acuerdo negociado pueden
mejorarse de acuerdo a los intereses del
país y que yo estoy muy anuente
renegociarlo con el compromiso de que no
incluirá más impuestos en su corta
trayectoria política chávez ya se ha
visto envuelto en varias polémicas el
mismo año que abandonó el banco mundial
este lo sancionó por acoso sexual a dos
de sus trabajadoras entre 2008 y 2013 y
recientemente el periódico wall street
journal publicó que chávez también
habría acosado a mujeres en indonesia
entre 2 1000 18 y 2019 acusaciones que
siempre ha negado
periodista quien tardó 12 semanas para
escribir la nota afirma que hubo una
conducta inapropiada necesidad de
indolencia y sabes como sustenta esa
temeraria afirmación
como gente familiarizada con el caso
el político muy popular entre los
costarricenses también ha sido señalado
por financiar su campaña con cuentas
bancarias no declaradas
a nuestros invitados vuelvo a
agradecerles por acompañarnos en este
especial sobre la posición de rodrigo
chávez como presidente de costa rica y
también le doy la bienvenida a cindy
regidor corresponsal de france 24 en
esta nación ella se encuentra en san
josé cindy buenos días para usted en
este momento vemos que no ha iniciado
formalmente
está este traspaso de poder en la sede
de la asamblea nacional pero cuenta nos
había hablado de una ceremonia austera
pero pues vemos que también tiene cuenta
con un centenar de delegaciones
internacionales cómo se está
desarrollando hasta el momento este
evento
hola buenos días bueno aquí un ambiente
bastante de festivo con muchas
presentaciones culturales
diferentes ballets folclóricos que han
venido de distintas partes del país para
engalanar la plaza de la democracia que
está contigua a la asamblea legislativa
en donde ya se encuentran los invitados
listos para que empiece la ceremonia de
traspaso de mando presidencial en costa
rica en la gente está viendo la mayoría
esta transmisión en sus casas a través
de la televisión mientras que en la
asamblea legislativa se encuentran ya
las delegaciones de los países y de
organismos internacionales que como lo
has dicho son casi un centenar entre
ellos se encuentran el rey felipe de
españa el presidente de colombia iván
duque el presidente de república
dominicana luis abinader y el presidente
de panamá laurentino cortizo también
importante que ha destacado en la
administración entrante la invitación de
los pueblos indígenas representantes de
poblaciones indígenas que hoy llegaron
aquí para también ser parte de este
solemne ejercicio
y el ambiente como te digo bastante
festivo aquí en los alrededores hay
bastante seguridad pero si también hay
personas que están en las cercanías para
poder apreciar la entrada de las
delegaciones hubo también una plegaria
un evento religiosa en el que participó
el presidente electo rodrigo chávez
conjunto con el presidente de la
conferencia episcopal de la iglesia
católica y un representante también un
líder de la iglesia evangélica
posteriormente ingresó aquí en la
asamblea legislativa para dar inicio a
este acto que está a pocos minutos de
aranda
cindy justamente en estos momentos vemos
las imágenes de la entrada del actual
presidente carlos alvarado el presidente
saliente y también le pregunto si hasta
este momento se conoce algunos de los
temas en torno a los que girará el
discurso del primer discurso de rodrigo
chávez como presidente del país
todavía no se conoce pero sí se sabe que
las conversaciones que han tenido el
presidente electo rodrigo chaves con su
gabinete ha dejado claro que la
prioridad del gobierno va a ser la
prosperidad mayor en generación de
empleos los ejes más importantes con los
que quiere empezar la administración una
serie de decretos que ayuden a bajar el
costo de la vida para las poblaciones
más vulnerables bueno que trascendió
tras las reuniones previas que tuvo con
su gabinete hoy por la tarde tendrá su
primer consejo del gobierno una vez que
concluya esta ceremonia así que
esperemos a ver qué dice sobre estos
temas que tiene en propuestas en
concreto al respecto y cuál será su
política en lo social y como ya
escuchábamos también en la nota acerca
de su trayectoria de su polémica en
cuanto al tema de derechos de género
y las acusaciones en su contra cuál
sería también la tónica en este sentido
hoy un parte del partido frente amplio
no asistieron ayer anunciaron que lo
harían una manera de protesta por esa
situación que se le achaca al presidente
electo rodrigo a chávez cindy a usted
muchas gracias le pido que por favor
continúe conectada con nosotros para
volver más adelante con usted costa rica
es un país de 52 millones de habitantes
que en 2021 registró un desempleo de
cerca del 14 por ciento y en 2020 la
cifra era del 24% la pobreza para el año
pasado se ubicaba en 23% mientras que en
2020 fue de 26,2 por ciento así que en
este momento empiezo preguntándole a
manuel bienvenido de nuevo aquí al
estudio de france 24 cuáles son las
condiciones en las que carlos alvarado
deja el país un país cuyo producto
interno bruto depende fuertemente del
turismo que se vio prácticamente
frenado por la pandemia claro bien has
dicho que carlos alvarado digamos deja
una economía en donde de alguna forma la
deuda externa del país ha aumentado
esto ha implicado un poco relacionado
con la cuestión del coi 19 y en ese
sentido también deja unos de alguna
forma unos índices positivos como es la
reducción de la pobreza obviamente no es
un índice digamos de un dígito como
todos los 300 querrían detenerlo pero
alguna forma deja un sinsabor de que
efectivamente deja el país endeudado
obviamente por los gastos sociales
asociados a la pandemia pero también
deja esos índices sociales un poco más
aliviados en términos de pobres bueno
pasó a hablar con nancy hernández ella
es politóloga en este momento se
encuentra en costa rica nancy bienvenida
y la pregunta lo mismo básicamente como
cuál son las condiciones en las que
carlos alvarado le entrega el país en
este momento a rodrigo chávez
buenos días mucho gusto estar aquí
compartiendo con ustedes pues si
efectivamente existen problemas
importantes ya lo mencionamos
anteriormente con el tema de desempleo
la depresión que es el principal
elemento y creo que el presidente electo
chávez ha sido muy claro en el sentido
de que los primeros decretos y las
primeras iniciativas van a ir estar
trabajando en temas de simplificación de
trámites
el tema de desempleo veremos han venido
tantos algunos temas por ejemplo con el
tema de reducción de el precio en las
medicinas que eventualmente podrían
empezar a sentirse un poco más en el en
el bolsillo porque obviamente y esto se
ha complicado con el tema de pandemia el
aumento en el empleo pues ha venido a
hacer a complicar mucho más las
condiciones que teníamos prepandémica
bueno en estos momentos justamente en
las imágenes que estamos viendo está
prácticamente llegando a la asamblea
legislativa el nuevo presidente del país
pero continuó
con alejandro molina él también es
politólogo también se encuentra en costa
rica y le pregunto su punto de vista
respecto a estas condiciones que vive la
nación en este momento
si en realidad hago eco de las dos
intervenciones anteriores
si agregó que la situación
socioeconómica del país se encuentra
sumamente deteriorada no únicamente a
raíz de estos últimos cuatro años de
gobierno del presidente saliente carlos
alvarado sino que son un reflejo de un
modelo de desarrollo consolidado desde
hace al menos cuatro décadas en el país
la frágil situación de las finanzas
públicas se viene manifestando desde
hace más de una década
debido justamente a las políticas
públicas implementadas para hacer frente
a la crisis financiera de 2008-2009 y
pareciera ser que de alguna forma la
manera en la que el actual gobierno
saliente repito ha intentado abordar la
problemática ha generado una
conflictividad social de las más altas
en las últimas décadas
tuvimos la huelga más extensa durante
este gobierno
la reforma fiscal impulsada a finales de
2018 precisamente para hacer frente a la
frágil situación de las finanzas
públicas y cuando en el año 2020 se
anuncia la negociación con el fondo
monetario internacional para acceder a
un empréstito que superan los 1.700
millones de dólares y las políticas que
se implementarían para demostrar al
fondo la capacidad de pago del país
también originó el ciclo de protesta
relativamente inédito en la historia
reciente del país entonces el presidente
chávez tendrá que hacer frente no
solamente a la frágil situación
económica que enfrenta el país sino
también a una situación política marcada
por la polarización y por la
conflictividad social
tanto a nivel político
político institucional a nivel formal
entre las distintas fuerzas políticas
representadas por ejemplo en el poder
legislativo y también a nivel social
entre los distintos movimientos sociales
sectores de la sociedad
durante estos cuatro años repito han
vivido situaciones de conflictividad es
sumamente notorias bueno vuelvo aquí al
estudio manuel y le pregunto cuál puede
ser considerado el principal legado del
presidente alvarado y también la
principal deuda que le queda con el
pueblo costarricense durante su
administración
bueno el principal legado creo yo que es
básicamente en lo relativo a los
derechos de las minorías sexuales y todo
lo que tiene que ver con la conquista de
derechos para los ciudadanos es decir el
partido de acción ciudadana es un
partido de centroizquierda que de alguna
forma se ha caracterizado para avanzar
en eso digamos en estos asuntos
obviamente su gran digamos deuda va a
ser en el tema económico obviamente
costarrica digamos llega hasta este año
con la premisa alguna forma de que
necesita un rescate del fondo monetario
internacional y obviamente el presidente
alvarado va a quedar digamos que el
presidente que no logró conseguir esa
digamos solución a un problema tan
urgente como lo fue o como lo es mejor
la crisis económica en costa rica
lance y pasó a preguntarle usted también
el principal logro y la principal deuda
que se puede resaltar del presidente
carlos alvarado que hoy deja el poder
concuerdo con el tema de derechos de
derechos humanos sin embargo me parece
que se da una base en la parte económica
e importante por lo menos para iniciar
nuevas negociaciones el acuerdo que se
firma con él con el fondo monetario da
la estabilidad para empezar a hacer y
ahora sí digamos en un periodo tal vez
post pandémico empezar con cambios
importantes y ya con función presidente
que chávez con una posible renegociación
de este acuerdo en cuanto a las a los
faltantes a las deudas me parece que el
tema de conectividad en la parte
educativa es un tema importante lo
sentimos en parte en el período
pandémico donde en el sector educativo
público marca una diferencia importante
con la educación privada en detrimento
obviamente de la educación pública donde
mucha nuestra población de niños y
jóvenes no tuvieron la posibilidad
de continuar de una manera normal
entrecomillado esté siguiendo con el
tema de
conexiones el universo que también el
tema de corrupción salió en algún
momento con algunos cuestionamientos que
se hizo a la presidencia y el presidente
carlos alvarado sobre el manejo de datos
personales de la ciudadanía y obviamente
que esto también se vio plasmado en el
cuestionamientos que se hacen a algunas
figuras de las alcaldías municipales en
costa rica por lo tanto el tema el tema
de corrupción vuelve nuevamente a tomar
un auge importante en el país y este
igual las respuestas que en algún
momento será un anhelado ejecutivo pues
no no no satisfacieron adecuadamente las
demandas de la ciudadanía así que me
parece que estos dos elementos aparte de
los que mencionaba manuel me parece que
son fundamentales en este caso
nancy la vamos a ir este momento hasta
san jose justamente a la asamblea donde
en este momento está juramentando el
nuevo presidente de costa rica rodrigo
chávez vamos a escuchar lo que está
ocurriendo allí
señor presidente le ruego
levantar su mano derecha
juráis adiós y prometéis a la patria
observar y defender la constitución y
las leyes de la república y cumplir
fielmente los deberes de vuestro destino
si uno
si así lo hiciera
dios os ayude y si no él es la patria os
lo demande
[Aplausos]
luego al señor presidente de un carlos
alvarado que sea
y al señor rodrigo alberto chávez robles
acompañarnos al frente de la mesa del
directorio para el acto de transmisión
del mando presidencial
[Aplausos]
pero justamente veíamos las imágenes en
las que rodrigo arias sánchez que es el
presidente de la asamblea legislativa le
impuso ya la banda presidencial al nuevo
jefe de estado a partir de este momento
rodrigo chávez ya es el nuevo mandatario
de costa rica- estábamos hablando con
nancy con manuel sobre el legado el
principal legado y la principal deuda de
carlos alvarado con el pueblo
costarricense y no quisiera pasar a otra
pregunta antes de hacerle este mismo
cuestionamiento a alejandro molina
quisiera conocer su opinión al respecto
si yo hago también nuevamente eco de la
respuesta que dio el compañero manuel
hay que recordar que en el año 2018 el
presidente saliente carlos alvarado gana
las elecciones en un contexto marcado
por la polarización alrededor de la
posibilidad de reconocer el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo en el país
parece ser que podemos afirmar que el
presidente ha cumplido pues con su
promesa de campaña y con la bandera que
que defendió en la campaña electoral en
la cual resultó electo alrededor de los
derechos civiles de estas poblaciones
sexualmente diversas en nuestro país la
principal deuda que deja el presidente
además como repito de la frágil
situación macroeconómica del país y el
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional
negociado pero que todavía no ha llegado
a buen puerto
a eso yo le sumaría lo que mencionaba
anteriormente sobre el diálogo social
sobre la apertura hacia demandas
plurales de la sociedad costarricense lo
que hemos resentido a lo largo de estos
cuatro años es que el presidente
alvarado se ha encontrado muy influido
por los grupos de poder económico grupos
de poder empresarial también que han
sido muy influyentes tanto desde puestos
de gobierno directamente a su gabinete
estuvo bastante nutrido de figuras
provenientes de estos grupos y también
alrededor de influencia quizás podríamos
llamar informal sobre su gobierno que
durante estos cuatro años han sido muy
marcados entonces podríamos afirmar que
la principal deuda al menos que
identificamos en el observatorio de
política nacional además de las
cuestiones políticas político económicas
y demás si están muy relacionadas con el
diálogo social como solución
la conflictividad y la polarización
tienen determinadas coyunturas se
manifiesta en el país no justamente
desde la redacción de france 24
preparamos un informe con el balance de
la nación que recibe rodrigo chávez
costa rica ya lo decíamos es considerado
uno de los países más estables y con
mayor respeto a la democracia en la
región no obstante durante los últimos
años se ha registrado un deterioro en
sus indicadores veamos más detalles en
el informe
es una de las democracias más sólidas de
latinoamérica pero costa rica también
enfrenta crecientes retos de pobreza
desempleo y criminalidad entre otros que
tendrá que asumir el nuevo presidente de
la nación no me comprometido y me
empeñaré en impulsar profundos y
positivos cambios en la forma de
gobernar costarrica
democráticamente y es que a pesar de que
costa rica está considerado como uno de
los países con mayor escolaridad calidad
y esperanza de vida de latinoamérica en
los últimos años se ha venido
registrando un deterioro en sus
indicadores económicos debido a un
escaso crecimiento económico agravado
por la pandemia de kobe 19 que debilitó
el turismo sector clave en el país por
lo que la nación centroamericana ha
visto crecer hasta el 23 por ciento su
índice de pobreza que estaba en torno al
21 por ciento antes de la pandemia y
hasta cerca del 14 por ciento el
desempleo superior también a los niveles
pre pandemia
esto está muy pobre no hay trabajo no
hay nada pero de ahora en adelante desde
que luche por este país porque somos
costarricenses tienen que luchar al
igual que durante el mandato de carlos
alvarado se espera que las políticas
ambientales estén en el centro del nuevo
gobierno ya que el país lleva la
delantera regional en el combate contra
la crisis climática con un ambicioso
plan de alcanzar la neutralidad
climática para 2050 lo que sí espero es
que las cosas que hemos logrado en estos
años es el liderazgo internacional en
materia climática o esa reivindicación
de derechos humanos o la estabilidad
macroeconómica no se eche para atrás
chávez también deberá combatir la
corrupción y el narcotráfico que ha ido
en aumento en el país debido a su
ubicación estratégica en la ruta del sur
al norte del continente una situación
con la que el nuevo presidente ha
prometido terminar pero ya veíamos un
poco más de la situación del país y le
pregunto a alejandro cuáles pueden ser
ya sabemos cuáles son los retos qué ante
el nuevo presidente tendrá que enfrentar
pero cuáles serían los más urgentes a
resolver
bueno el más urgente a resolver
corresponde principalmente al acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional que
se negocia en este momento que inició la
negociación
el presidente saliente carlos alvarado
eso será el principal condicionante que
tendrá por ejemplo el poder legislativo
la asamblea legislativa ya que hay que
recordar que durante estos primeros
meses de gobierno el presidente chávez
la agenda de la asamblea legislativa
vendrá dada por el poder ejecutivo por
primera vez en la historia ya que
previamente iniciaba la asamblea
legislativa la agenda al cuando iniciaba
un nuevo gobierno una nueva
administración
este acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional el mismo presidente chávez
ha afirmado que va a renegociar que va a
incluso a proponer metas más ambiciosas
que las propuestas que sigue las
propuestas por el presidente saliente
carlos alvarado entonces este desafío
urgente
se
complementa o se contextualiza
principalmente con la frágil situación
económica que maneja el país actualmente
pero también por la urgencia de lograr
un acuerdo con el fondo que es como digo
un condicionante principal que deja a la
administración alvarado quesada al
gobierno del presidente rodrigo chats me
dirijo a usted nancy le pregunto si
usted considera también que este acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional es
el reto más urgente que enfrenta el
presidente chávez ahora que llega a la
casa presidencial
sin lugar a dudas sin lugar a duda pero
yo antes que el tema del fondo monetario
rescato dos temas vamos a ver llamémoslo
de mayor habilidad política el primero
es el tema del crear equipo porque
porque el partido social democrático es
un partido realmente nuevo en el en el
ámbito costarricense nace en el 2018 más
o menos nunca ha tenido participación a
nivel político ni a nivel local ni al
nivel normal a excepción de esta de este
proceso electoral por lo tanto a la hora
de crear equipo la forma en que se
seleccionaron las diferentes
personalidades ministros viceministros
presidencias ejecutivas
ese fue un poco atípico a lo que estamos
acostumbrados puesto que pensamos
siempre que estas figuras nacen de los
ceros de los partidos políticos en el
caso de del presidente chávez realiza un
proceso de selección un poco más
llamémoslo vamos a ver también un poco
más de de la escuela del sector privado
sacó un proceso de selección entonces
tenemos en este momento una conformación
de un gabinete que viene efectivamente
con poca experiencia política no así de
experiencia laboral pero que va a
anticipar el presidente chávez una gran
capacidad de coordinación y de liderazgo
para que el equipo entienda claramente
cuáles son sus en sus prioridades y sus
funciones y a esto le uno me da el hecho
que en yale ya lo mencionaba
anteriormente alejando que en el caso de
la asamblea legislativa costarricense el
partido no tiene mayoría de diputados y
a su vez inicia con este marcando la
agencia la agenda legislativa entonces
aquí la figura de la ministra de la
presidencia va a ser fundamental porque
está clara en este momento el presidente
ha marcado muy claramente cuáles van a
ser las funciones de sus vicepresidentes
cuáles van a ser su función a nivel de
equipo acción de equipo de gobierno y
ser el hombre cómo está cómo estaría
trabajando la ministra de la presidencia
entonces el tema de tener un diálogo
constante un diálogo permanente que
también fue una de las críticas que se
le hizo al ex presidente alvarado en el
sentido de tener esa comunicación esa
negociación para que efectivamente la
agenda a nivel del legislativo vaya vaya
caminando y vaya y vaya dándose
consensos acuerdos y éste me parecen
todos esos dos elementos junto que lo
que ya mencionamos de leer
del acuerdo del fondo monetario me
parece que son fundamentales por lo
menos en estos primeros meses para
empezar a trabajar a nivel del ejecutivo
y por último le pregunta manuel cuál es
su punto de vista al respecto es
compañeros de panel y es efectivamente
formar gobiernos y no hay un gobierno
pues obviamente el acuerdo se va a caer
porque no existe la aprobación del ente
legislativa y en ese sentido yo creo que
la falta de cuadros que tiene el partido
de gobierno es decir la falta de
políticos experimentados va a traer a
pasar factura al nuevo gobierno en el
sentido de que no haber un enlace una
comunicación entre la presidencia y
obviamente el congreso para tratar de
conciliar la agenda y en ese sentido de
alguna forma el acuerdo depende depende
de que efectivamente en un congreso que
obviamente está con mayoría opositora
pues obviamente no va a tener digamos
una confiabilidad muy mayor digámoslo
así en torno a que los que busca el
presidente chávez con el nuevo acuerdo
pues es lo que al final de cuentas
piense o trate de aprobar el digamos el
parlamento entonces yo creo que más allá
de la cuestión del acuerdo es
básicamente formar gobierno formar
gobernabilidad para que digamos no
solamente el acuerdo sino otros temas de
la agenda las costarricenses pues fluyan
de manera armónica entre ambos poderes
claro bueno ahora volvamos un poco a la
figura que representa rodrigo chávez
para acostar rical se presentó en
campaña como lo que se conoce como un
outsider político rompe con el llamado
establishment se le considera neoliberal
en materia económica pero tiene una
ideología bastante conservadora en otro
sentido le pregunto a alejandro molina
cómo ve usted el perfil del nuevo
presidente
el perfil de don rodrigo chávez es el de
típicamente un tecnócrata
precisamente por su carrera de varias
décadas en el banco mundial su campaña
política y su campaña electoral intentó
vender esta imagen de don rodrigo chávez
como un outsider como un pepito como un
tecnócrata proveniente del banco mundial
que ha sabido manejar crisis en otros
países
ha sido como decía nancy un partido que
cuenta con muy pocos cuadros es un
partido nuevo poco institucionalizado y
ha basado su campaña en un personalismo
muy marcado tanto al inicio por la
figura de doña pilar cisneros que era
candidata diputada por el primer lugar
en la provincia de san josé
ella es una persona muy reconocida aquí
en el país porque fue la presentadora el
principal noticiero aquí en costa rica y
durante muchas décadas se ganó este
prestigio de persona beligerante en
contraer la corrupción y en la campaña
de don rodrigo chávez ha servido para
fortalecer ese mensaje y esa
beligerancia contra la corrupción que el
ahora presidente le achaca a los
partidos tradicionales una vez que ese
personalismo de doña pilar cisneros
logró también abrir paso para un
personalismo muy marcado alrededor de un
rodrigo de chávez
ha abierto o se ha creado esta imagen de
un rodrigo como repito como un político
que no es no pertenece a ese a ese grupo
de partidos políticos tradicionales sino
que es un outsider y un tecnócrata que
más allá de cuestiones políticas él sabe
hacer que las cosas sucedan por eso es
que hago eco de la intervención previa
de nancy en la que ella mencionaba que
el proceso de selección de su equipo de
gobierno se ha realizado siguiendo
parámetros muy empresariales muy
gerenciales precisamente porque don
rodrigo chávez ha sido muy beligerante
en la forma en que opera el sector
público costarricense y forma parte de
esta ola de políticos que
promueven que el estado costarricense
funcione similar a cómo funcionaría una
empresa privada oa una empresa
transnacional entonces el perfil de don
rodrigo se mueve mucho entre éste
personalismo con su carácter no político
de político no tradicional que invoca la
anti política en su discurso
precisamente para fortalecer esa imagen
de outsider que ha intentado vender como
decía estoy mencionando para ahora le
pregunto a nancy usted cómo describiría
al nuevo mandatario también podemos
hablar un poco más allá sabemos que
costa rica en este momento requiere la
reactivación económica y que estos
índices mejoren pero también como lo ven
ustedes en cuestión de derechos humanos
por ejemplo
bien vamos a ver
rodrigo nadie con cuando completamente
con alejandro se presenta como un
tecnócrata claramente con una
experiencia y una vasta experiencia en
tema de manejo de crisis económica que
es en este momento me parece que el
principal problema que tiene costa rica
en ese sentido e incluso se presenta
como nancy discúlpame como discúlpame
que la tengo que interrumpir en este
momento va a hablar rodrigo chávez desde
la asamblea legislativa de costa rica
a marzo y necesita
excelentísimos jefes de delegación
internacional que nos acompañan y nos
honran con su presencia
señor diputado presidente de la asamblea
legislativa
señoras y señores diputados
señor magistrado presidente de la corte
suprema de justicia
señoras y señores magistrados
señora magistrada
presidente de la corte
del tribunal supremo de elecciones
señoras y señores magistrados
señor vicepresidente y señora
vicepresidenta de la república señor
miguel ángel rodríguez echeverría y
señor carlos alvarado quesada ex
presidente de la república
señora claudia dobles camargo ex primera
dama de la república
señora y señor ex
vicepresidentes de la república
deben de revender y ximo
arzobispo de san josé y señores obispos
de la conferencia episcopal y señores de
la alianza evangélica
señoras y señores ministros de gobierno
designados
y excelentísimos miembros de misiones
diplomáticas acreditadas en el país
señora contralora y señor sub contralor
general de la república
señoras y señores viceministros de
gobierno designados señor procurador
general y señora procuradora general
adjunta de la republica señoras
defensoras defensora y defensora adjunta
de los habitantes de la república
honorable representantes de organismos
internacionales
y cónsules cónsules honorarios
señoras y señores presidentes ejecutivos
de instituciones autónomas designados
representantes de los pueblos indígenas
costarricenses que nos acompañan
costarricenses compatriotas
con la solemnidad
gravedad y sentido de responsabilidad
histórica que la época nos impone me
honré de recibir esta banda presidencial
en tiempos de desafíos importantísimos
no solo para el futuro de nuestro país
sino para el destino mismo de la
humanidad el pueblo costarricense al
elegir me puso en mis manos la
responsabilidad de conducir el destino
patrio durante los próximos cuatro años
con reverencia y muchísima humildad les
digo tienen y tendrán en mí durante todo
este periodo a un fiel mandatario es
decir a alguien que a partir de este
instante y hasta el 8 de mayo del
aspirará con todos mis esfuerzos
qatar la calidad del mandato de usted es
cumplir y hacer que se cumpla la
voluntad de un pueblo soberano en todos
los quehaceres del estado dentro del
marco riguroso del derecho que nos rige
el momento que vivimos es crucial
somos los llamados a realizar un cambio
histórico
y ese llamado se impone con la fuerza de
la voz del pueblo que demandó desde las
urnas una
obligación enorme a toda la clase
política del país lo que incluye por
supuesto a los tres poderes de la
república
es el momento
de dejar atrás las viejas prácticas que
tanto nos cobra y con razón el pueblo
costarricense
aquí no hay
distingos diferencias entre oficialismo
y oposición
si la clase política falla una vez más
nuestro país se podría desmoronar
nos estamos viendo ante un espejo
cuya imagen no nos gusta porque nos
presenta dos caras que no parecieran
conciliarse nos estamos viendo ante un
espejo cuya imagen
esta y encuentra el rostro de un país
cuyo nivel de educación había sido
ejemplar en la región latinoamericana
pero cuya calidad de la educación se ha
ido deteriorando
lo que compromete hoy a mediano y a
largo plazo la prosperidad de nuestro
país
el octavo informe del estado de la
educación
nos ha confrontado con una dolorosa
imagen la pandemia del cobi 19 causó un
apagón educativo que cayó como un mazazo
repentino y cruel sobre miles de niños y
adolescentes en nuestra patria
pero esto no hizo más que evidenciar las
diferencias que ya existían entre las
zonas rurales y urbanas entre quienes
gozaban de conectividad e internet y
quienes no tenían acceso ni todavía lo
tienen a la tecnología que les permita
seguir asistiendo a la escuela o al
colegio desde sus casas
en resumen los menos beneficiados y las
clases más vulnerables de nuestra patria
no es por casualidad que en el año 2020
antes de la pandemia el 60% de las
personas con edades entre 18 y 22 años
dijeran que ellos no habían terminado la
educación secundaria
vemos en ese espejo el resto el rostro
de la gente trabajadora de gente que se
ha preocupado por formarse con la
esperanza de que sus familias tengan el
nivel de vida que anhelan que se merece
o que a pesar de no contar con estudios
formales han utilizado su ingenio y su
capacidad de trabajo para salir adelante
pero al mismo tiempo ese rostro es el
mismo de cientos de miles de personas
que van a ver acabar el día de hoy sin
un empleo con el cual enfrentarse a las
necesidades personales de la mañana
siguiente
es también el rostro de casi un millón
de personas
atrapadas en el en el empleo informal es
un país cuyo suelo tiene la capacidad de
alimentarnos a todos ya todas pero es
también un país donde el hambre se posa
en la mesa de cientos de miles de
personas que no ganan lo suficiente ni
siquiera para comprar los alimentos más
básicos de la canasta de consumo
es un país cuya democracia
bicentenaria de comprobado arraigo en
nuestra cultura cívica ha cautivado a
los pueblos del mundo
pero a su vez vemos en ese espejo de la
realidad de hoy en el que nos miramos
desapego y desconfianza de los partidos
y la política tradicional
que no implica bajo ningún punto de
vista
renuncia de negación alguna a los
valores democráticos
sino que por el contrario
expresa el deseo de una vivencia más
auténtica de la democracia y supone una
valoración más genuina y trascendente de
sus prácticas fundamentales
la imagen reflejada en ese espejo es la
de un país que a lo largo de las décadas
ha construido una institucionalidad
fuerte
robusta pero que durante los últimos
años ha visto sí con vergüenza
con impotencia y con gusto enojo como
las instituciones no han sabido brindar
servicios públicos de calidad ni limpiar
las estructuras del lastre infame de la
corrupción
las indignantes listas de espera de la
caja costarricense de seguro social
nuestra institución que amamos tanto
esas listas de espera han sometido a
miles de costarricenses
no sólo es una violación sistemática al
derecho a la salud
sino que esa lista de espera son
humillantes y angustiantes para quienes
la atención médica significa vida
o muerto
ni los fallos de la sala constitucional
han hecho mover los cimientos de la caja
en ese sentido
nos miramos con asombro en ese espejo
porque no es la costa rica- que deseamos
no no decíamos el país donde las calles
nos gastan la vida empresas
interminables
no decíamos el país de las zonas rurales
que ven con tristeza
y desamparo a lo lejos allá como el
desarrollo y la economía casi que sólo
crecen en la zona central del país
este es el espejo en el que nos estamos
mirando todas y todos compatriotas un
espejo lleno de contradicciones de
sueños que se niegan a formar parte de
nuestra realidad de sueños que no tienen
los zapatos para correr mucho menos las
alas para volar
y esas contradicciones son más que
cifras en estudios económicos y
académicos
son más que alarmantes datos que año
tras año nos da a conocer
investigación como la del estado de la
nación esas contradicciones nos duelen
nos lastiman esas contradicciones hacen
que la vida de nuestros ciudadanos sea
más dura más difícil de lo que debería
ser en un país democrático
pacífico
rico como el nuestro
esas contradicciones duelen en el pan
ausente sobre la mesa duelen en los
jóvenes que deben tomar la difícil
decisión de dejar sus estudios para
contribuir con el sustento familiar o
peor aún en los y las jóvenes que han
caído en el agujero sin fondo de la
drogadicción o que han que han pasado a
engrosar las filas del crimen organizado
compatriotas
seremos capaces de hacer historia
con patriotas seremos capaces de llevar
realmente a costa rica hacia el futuro
que ustedes se merecen
seremos capaces de hacer que las
personas que habitan en este gran país
vuelvan a soñar y no solo a soñar sino a
tener la oportunidad de construir en
realidad sus sueños
esos señores y señores
esos son los grandes desafíos que
tenemos que vencer
sé muy bien
que el reto parece durísimo
y francamente lo es pero compatriotas no
caigamos no caigamos en la trampa de la
desesperanza no nos dejemos vencer por
la oscuridad que han querido vendernos
como si quisieran hacernos pensar que el
cambio y el progreso no son posibles
alguna gente
algunos prominentes de la clase política
de este país con ligereza y quizá como
excusa para 9 para no haber tomado las
decisiones que correspondía tomar nos
han hecho que creer nos han hecho creer
que costa rica es un país ingobernable
no
no no se trata de ingobernabilidad se
trata de tomar las decisiones que son
necesarias que tomemos sin importar lo
complejas o controversiales que puedan
llegar a ser
es una cuestión de valentía
aunque estas decisiones vayan en contra
de los intereses de grupos pequeños los
que han utilizado
su influencia y poder
para beneficiarse de políticas públicas
que no han hecho más que disminuir el
bienestar de la mayoría
la patria desdicha
dolor y cielo de todos y no feudo ni
capellanía de nadie nos dijo josé martí
con palabras que nos hablan no desde el
pasado sino desde la actualidad tremenda
desde la lucha permanente por el anhelo
del bien común
expresado en la voluntad ciudadana
tengo clarísimo muy claro en mi corazón
que si pongo por delante el faro de esa
voluntad ciudadana nunca me perderé
si pongo por delante el camino que me
han trazado cada una de las mujeres y
hombres que votaron por mí
y también quienes no lo hicieron
jamás usaré la excusa de que este país
no puede gobernarse
porque la orden del pueblo es que
necesitamos gobernar
y que lo haga con liderazgo con energía
con decisión con humildad pero sobre
todo con la convicción de que cada una
de mis decisiones y las de mi equipo
tienen como guía una voluntad que ha
hablado que nos demanda que nos exige
actuar por el bien de la mayoría la
voluntad del pueblo
digo esto por supuesto
teniendo más presente que ninguno que el
cambio que exige el país no se trata de
una ambición ni un proyecto personal de
un hombre llamado rodrigo chávez en este
caso sino del rescate de la democracia y
eso nos compromete a todos los
costarricenses
en la extensa historia de más de 200
años de vida democrática del país
este
posible accidente histórico
este para muchos
impredecible revés de los órdenes
políticos viene a plantear la
posibilidad de cambiar definitivamente
el curso de nuestras vidas
como dijo la famosa socióloga margarit
nunca dudé de que un pequeño grupo de
ciudadanos reflexivos y comprometidos
puede cambiar el mundo de hecho eso es
lo único que lo ha logrado
este cambio
este cambio no puede ser alcanzado por
la voluntad de una sola persona
este cambio necesita del carácter de los
millones de costarricenses que con su
trabajo honrado y entreguen cuestionable
construyen la patria día a día
costarricenses que han demostrado
incontables veces la grandeza de su
espíritu al dejar en alto nuestro país
en las disciplinas más variadas del
deporte en la forma más bella del arte y
en los más innovadores de los
descubrimientos e investigaciones
científicas costarricenses que
desde las muy
diversas y complejas condiciones que
viven hoy están procurando con el mejor
de sus esfuerzos con la franqueza de sus
acciones y el compromiso de sus labores
el sustento honrado de sus mesas y la
modesta tranquilidad de sus familias
sé que en este momento muchos de estos
valientes compatriotas
deben estar viendo o escuchando este
discurso desde sus hogares
preocupados más por el hambre que
arremete contra sus cuerpos que por la
posible virtud que puedan encontrar en
las palabras de este servidor humilde de
ustedes que les habla estoy consciente
de que mi elocuencia tiene que ser la
mejora de las condiciones de vida de
miles de costarricenses y no la
elocuencia de un discurso
sé que muchos otros
desencantados por el fantasma de las
ilusiones incumplidas de gobiernos
anteriores no se tomarán ni siquiera la
molestia de acompañar con oído atento
las palabras sencillas de este hombre
que hoy decidieron nombrar con tan
altísimo honor
a todos ustedes me dirijo y les digo vea
me como lo que soy un instrumento
humilde para cumplir con el mandato del
pueblo un pueblo que unido puede de
lograr el campo bueno veíamos al nuevo
presidente de costa rica rodrigo chávez
en un discurso bastante general incluso
un poco ambiguo en el que no ha hecho
mayores promesas o propuestas de hecho
han sido más los cuestionamientos sobre
si su gobierno será capaz de lograr los
retos que enfrenta el país habló de su
sentido de responsabilidad dijo que es
histórica y que implica lo que implica
recibir la banda presidencial en estos
tiempos que son fundamentales para costa
rica y también para la humanidad también
dijo que tiene la responsabilidad de
conducir el destino de la nación en los
próximos cuatro años y aseguró que será
un fiel mandatario que acatar a
cabalidad el mandato para el que fue
elegido su gobierno es el llamado a
realizar un cambio histórico un llamado
que se impone con la fuerza de la voz
del pueblo destacó que la situación de
la educación puesto en riesgo la
situación del país y hablo de la
pandemia como causante de un apagón
educativo que además generó una mayor
brecha entre las zonas urbanas y rurales
lo de la importancia de la reactivación
del empleo y principalmente del empleo
formal
también dijo que el hambre está en la
mesa de miles de personas que no ganan
lo suficiente para alimentarse se
refirió a la atención médica en el país
surgió mejorar los tiempos de espera
indicó que le esperan tiempos duros
retos duros pero le pidió a los
costarricenses que mantengan la
esperanza también habló de políticas
públicas que hasta el momento se han
tomado sin tener en cuenta el bienestar
de todos y por ello destacó que va a
actuar desde la voluntad ciudadana de
sus electores y también del resto de
votantes del país dijo que nunca va a
usar la excusa de no poder gobernar a
costa rica y se comprometió a ser un
líder enérgico pero al mismo tiempo
humilde vuelvo a san josé donde se
encuentra nuestra corresponsal cindy
regidor y justamente le pregunto qué
otras conclusiones se pueden sacar de
este 1er y que aún no termina pero que
ya lleva un buen tiempo del nuevo
mandatario
lo que pudimos escuchar la hora
presidente rodrigo chávez se enfocará en
lo que ha venido hablando durante su
cabaña y también una vez que se
colecciona enfocarse en las prioridades
económicas generar mayor empleo es
cerrar la brecha de la desigualdad
perdón escuchar un empate en los
corazones que fueron los que votaron por
él y las de las zonas costeras las
personas que se encuentran con índices
de mayor desempleo aunque se encuentran
en situaciones de mayor vulnerabilidad
mientras en la zona central o más cerca
de la gran área metropolitana las
personas se han podido recuperar mucho
más rápido de la pandemia vemos que como
universidades argentinas hay mucha
generalidad pero todo siempre en torno
al tema de la mejoría del bienestar de
la caudal de obra de los costarricenses
creo importante también destacar la
importancia que le da el presidente
rodrigo chau
hay aditivo entre comercialismo y
oposición para poder cumplirle a la
ciudadanía costarricense en lo que
demanda a través una mejorada de su
parada de vida habla también y reconoce
y nikhil además gracia en tu camino a
una democracia bicentenaria es una
democracia que también está siendo
afectada por la desconfianza que hay
entre los electores y los partidos
tradicionales 17 no veremos resultados
de la emisión pasada en la el
apresamiento que fue el más alto en la
historia del país para la
institucionalidad pero no ha sabido
brindar de este servicio en público nada
de accidente había corrupción esta parte
de la corrupción también fue importante
sin decía así es cambio él dice que el
cambio que exige el país no es un cambio
un proyecto personal suyo sino de un
rescate a la democracia que compromete a
todos los habitantes del país entonces
vemos un poco también que se repite algo
de lo que él mismo dijo el día en el que
fue elegido en esa segunda vuelta del 3
de abril cuando también habló de ser un
presidente para sus seguidores como para
sus detractores
cuando hablo también de este peso de la
responsabilidad que le llega con el
cargo de presidente síndico
bueno en estos momentos parece que
tenemos un poco de dificultad para
conectar con nuestra corresponsal
entonces vuelvo aquí a la el análisis
que tenemos con nuestros invitados
estaba hablando nancy hernández cuando
tuve que interrumpir la porque empezó el
pronunciamiento del presidente chávez
justamente le estaba preguntando cómo ve
el perfil del nuevo mandatario
20 un poco retomando las palabras
anteriores
concuerdo bueno completamente con con la
apreciación de que don rodrigo se
presenta como un tecnócrata pero no
toman con amplia experiencia
casi prácticamente
viendo temas y ahora lo vimos en el
discurso con temas de anticorrupción
como como parte de ese proceso así es el
gasto y hemos tenido en la en la
sociedad costarricense se le achacan
obviamente lo se mencionaba en un
principio todo lo toda la situación que
se presenta por su por su sanción en
temas de acoso en el en el banco en el
banco mundial y por ende se hace un
ligue directo con él con el tema de
derechos humanos sin embargo me parece
que más allá y hoy vimos algunas
pinceladas lo hemos estado bien en
algunas pinceladas de acciones concretas
en el accionar del gobierno por ejemplo
hoy tuvimos por primera vez
20 años de traspaso representación de
los pueblos originarios tuvimos la
presencia de la primera cacique
costarricense que representa a una de
las etnias esos esos elementos uno
podría ver a este un poco escuchando al
señor presidente en poder pensar que el
tema de derechos humanos lo puedan lo
podamos ver también una forma más amplia
y me parece que salían al punto que
quiero ayudar me hasta lo que hemos
escuchado no hemos terminado sociales al
señor presidente pero me parece que nos
falta escuchar temas sobre discapacidad
por ejemplo ya mencionó el tema de las
zonas costeras que si bien es cierto le
dan este abogado rodrigo un gran aula en
la parte 2 de los votos nos gustaría a
ver lo que obviamente hará la al haber
políticas públicas en la que toquen el
tema de las zonas costeras la zona de la
provincia ha llevado a la provincia de
guanacaste y la provincia de puntarenas
en el tema de discapacidad obviamente es
un tema que todavía no sale digamos
dentro de ese gran espectro de derechos
humanos y también en el tema de puede
tratar algo no menciona la parte de
desempleo pero no es solamente eso es de
ver el tema de niñez y adolescencia para
el ingreso de la de las poblaciones
jóvenes a fuentes laborales con salarios
sin alcohol bueno esos son elementos que
todavía están que están ausentes no
fueron tocados no fueron abordados en
campaña política en mi punto rodrigo
solamente este el tema de
su sanción en temas de acoso y lo
lograremos es eso es parte de lo que
vamos a ir viendo durante durante este
este proceso uno va viendo también aquí
en el balón brando verdad en las
diferencias a presidentas ejecutivas y
en los diferentes ministerios más o
menos para ir del mismo bando como
podría llegar a ser y cómo podría llegar
a analizarse el tema de el tema de
problema el tema de inclusión el tema de
derechos humanos ampliando no solamente
a la población de sexualidad diversa
sino también a otros tipos de
poblaciones que en este momento está
necesitando de acciones más fuertes de
políticas públicas más allá de un
discurso político sino de acciones
concretas que efectivamente le permitan
a la población costarricense que ir
ingresando e ir insertando se para
efectivamente empezar a
entender que el tema de equidad ven ahí
el tema de igualdad se da por medio de
una serie de acciones desde que ya
iniciamos y yo creo que el avance que
hace el presidente alvarado en ese
sentido es importante y así se ha
reconocido pero lo que viene ahora es
mucho más importante en el sentido de
afianzar y ampliar ese acceso a
igualdades para una mayor cantidad de
población
costarricense que así se lo está
demandando así lo ha dicho en las urnas
y se lo ha dicho en reiteradas ocasiones
tenemos tres elecciones donde el peso
que hacen las zonas costeras es
importante
bueno no voy a cambiar de pregunta y
sigo con usted porque ya usted lo
mencionaba sabemos que él estuvo
envuelto en un escándalo por denuncias
de acoso sexual mientras trabajaba en el
banco mundial- mujeres afirmaron que
intentó besar a empleadas de menor rango
que les hizo comentarios sexuales sobre
su apariencia y que incluso realizó
invitaciones no deseadas habitaciones de
hotel ya cenas la institución no lo
sancionó no lo sancionó pero no lo
despidió en ese momento justamente el
mes pasado chávez pidió perdón por su
comportamiento pero qué mensaje envía
que una persona envuelta en una
situación de este tipo sea presidente
realmente pesa esto dentro de costa
rica- pesa tanto como lo vemos de pronto
en otros lugares del mundo
cuando uno lo ve en el tema del peso de
las de las votaciones
este es el tema si bien es cierto se
analizó se tocó a nivel de encuesta a
nivel de votación no perdió tanto como
en algunos algunos partidos políticos
estuvieron intentando no ser en el hecho
de pedir perdón me parece que ha liviano
en alguna medida y esto meramente en
temas electorales alinean un poco la el
tema lamentablemente este tema no pensó
en la gran mayoría de la población que
priva el tema de desempleo como tema
prioritario el tema de corrupción como
tema prioritario y este tema
prácticamente no peso a la hora de hacer
un balance de por qué candidato o por
qué candidatura votar en ese en ese
momento me parece que lo que toca ahora
don rodrigo demostrar es efectivamente
es eso
y como uno ha dicho en reiteradas
ocasiones
fue un error que no debió ocurrir que no
debía ocurrirle así lo ha reconocido
públicamente
este y que no volverá a pasar bueno esto
esto es parte y creo que en el fin de
semana el viernes fue a meter esa semana
en el partido este frente a no se lo
hizo saber muy claramente de que van a
estar vigilantes yo creo que los grupos
de más cerca por lo con los grupos
feministas e igualmente grupos más
cercanos a
una ideología de género dado que el
partido 8 ciudadana no va a tener
representación en el en el de un estrato
legislativo el partido el frente amplio
está retomando el tema y se lo dijo
directamente el viernes pasado estaremos
vigilantes bueno eso es parte pero que
me parece empezar a marcar la cancha al
ejecutivo de cuáles temas van a ser y
deben ser tocados de importancia
manuel le hago la misma pregunta usted
cómo se interpreta usted que está en el
extranjero que no está en costa rica
cómo se interpreta que una persona que a
esta situación a cuestas sea elegida
presidente hoy sea presidente de un país
bueno parece muy desafortunado dicen que
explicaciones no pedidas o sacuda a su
acusación manifiesta entonces de alguna
forma tenemos un presidente que carga
con la sombra de que es un acosador si
eso lo vemos en temas personales miremos
los extrapolados en temas mucho más
complicados y más digamos de mayor nivel
a nivel nacional no es decir es una
persona que uno podría definir como
autoritaria de hecho incluso si veamos
en el discurso es una persona muy
personalista tiene muy es muy confiada
es muy enérgica y eso alguna forma puede
tener digamos muchos problemas a futuro
en el sentido de que no es una persona
con la cual se pueda dialogar fácilmente
sino que va a tratar de imponer su
criterio y eso se lo ha hecho saber
incluso a sus ministros y es que los
ministros no pueden jugar sin el
presidente el presidente es el que los
dirige sólo acabo de decir digamos hace
hace unos días en ese sentido vemos cuál
es la línea o es el talante de este
presidente no solamente desde el nivel
personal sino también el nivel de equipo
y en el nivel de gobierno entonces
obviamente estas acusaciones de acoso
pues revelan un poco esa personalidad un
poco oculta que trata de ocultar chávez
a la hora de m ya hemos de asumir la
presidencia y mantenerse como una
persona conciliadora bueno y siendo
cierro esta misma ronda haciendo la
pregunta alejandro molina en su opinión
desde su punto de vista que tanto pesan
y que tanto pueden hablar estas
acusaciones o estos comportamientos del
nuevo mandatario
a ver a nivel interno de costa rica hay
que contextualizar el hecho de que estas
acusaciones y esta sanción recibida por
rodrigo de chávez fueron conocidas por
el país por una publicación del diario
la nación que es el principal diario de
prensa escrita en el país alrededor de
mediados del 2021 cuando todavía la
campaña electoral no había iniciado
oficialmente según el tribunal supremo
de elecciones
entonces fueron fue una revelación que
sucedió llamémoslo de manera muy
temprana en la carrera electoral y en
ese entonces don rodrigo chávez todavía
no era un candidato que sonará con
fuerza que tuvieron intención de voto
notable
para de cara a hacerse con la banda
presidencial en febrero o eventualmente
en la segunda ronda de abril de este año
con lo cual el impacto que tuvo esta
revelación se encontró muy limitada como
digo a una etapa muy temprana de la
campaña electoral
cuando nos acercábamos todavía más a la
realización de los comicios primero en
febrero de este año observamos como las
acusaciones por acoso sexual y la
sanción recibida empezaron a pasar a un
segundo plano cuando don rodrigo empezó
a ganar fuerza como un candidato
anticorrupción un candidato anti
política tradicional y básicamente se
terminó imponiendo una narrativa según
la cual estos acusan estas acusaciones o
estas conductas muy propias del ámbito
privado quedaban en un segundo plano en
frente
problemáticas entre comillas más
urgentes en el ámbito público encuestas
y estudios de opinión como los que
realizamos en la universidad de costa
rica revelan que efectivamente no n
dentro del electorado la intención de
votar por rodrigo de chávez no se
afectaba a la hora de conocer estas
acusaciones de acoso sexual de cara a la
segunda ronda
sabíamos que el don rodrigo tenía estas
acusaciones y que su contrincante el ex
presidente josé maría figueres
arrastrado a otros cuestionamientos por
presunta corrupción y las conclusiones a
las que llegábamos con base en estos
estudios de opinión es que a don josé
maría figueres al ex presidente figueres
le pesaba muchísimo más la imagen de
corrupto que maneja en determinados
sectores de la población costarricense
que la imagen de acosador sexual que
podía manejar don rodrigo entonces a
nivel interno parece ser que este este
antecedente que sin duda alguna mancha
la hoja de vida de don rodrigo y que
se puede pasar por alto pareciera ser
que dentro de la población costarricense
quienes son partidarios de su figura no
no ejercen o mueve la aguja por decirlo
de alguna manera a nivel internacional
si hemos sabido que por ejemplo diarios
de muchísimo prestigio como lo puede ser
el wall street journal le han dado
bastante seguimiento a la situación que
se ha manejado entre donde drigo chávez
el banco mundial esta sanción y que de
alguna manera han tenido eco fuera de
nuestras fronteras pero repito a nivel
interno pareciera ser que eso no golpea
tanto su imagen como porque al ser a
nivel de cultura política pareciera ser
que estos aspectos propios del ámbito
privado quedan en un segundo plano
cuando discutimos
problemáticas más relacionadas con el
ámbito de lo público bueno y vuelvo en
este momento a san jose con cindy
regidor nuestra corresponsal de france
24 ya el nuevo presidente finalizó su
discurso oficial su primer
pronunciamiento como mandatario y se le
preguntó cindy vimos un discurso ambiguo
lo decíamos no se vieron tantas
propuestas de pronto como se esperaba
cuál es su balance respecto a este
pronunciamiento
definitivamente mucha generalidad pero
por otro lado también creo que le dio a
su público a su audiencia a las personas
que votaron por él les reafirmó su
compromiso de trabajar por ellas y dejó
a un lado entrar en temas polémicos por
supuesto como el que ya se referían
ustedes sobre el tema de la sanción por
acoso sexual me gustaría comentarte
valentina antes de irnos de que a unas
700 metros de acá cerca de la plaza de
la cultura un grupo de personas de
manifesto continúa manifestando con
pancartas rechazando el acoso sexual
hacia las mujeres del machismo la
misoginia y eso es parte de la sombra de
la que hablaba no especialistas allá
contigo y bueno definitivamente el
discurso todavía no integró propuestas
concretas pero si el presidente está
claro que necesita trabajar con la
oposición para poder devolverle la
esperanza a los costarricenses y lograr
esos cambios históricos de los que
hablaba al inicio sintió a usted muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado por
haber participado en este especial desde
san jose
ya que estamos hablando un poco de este
tema de derechos de las mujeres algo que
preocupa del mandatario es que durante
su campaña el prometió revisar las
normativas sobre la fecundación in vitro
y sobre el aborto
recordemos que en costa rica el aborto
sólo es legal cuando el embarazo pone en
peligro la vida de la mujer en abril la
conferencia episcopal de costa rica le
envió una carta a chávez pidiéndole que
su gobierno esté a favor de la vida y de
la familia y que le cierra las puertas
al aborto ya la eutanasia que se puede
esperar en materia de derechos sabiendo
que pues no todo depende de él que
dichas reformas también tienen que pasar
por el congreso le pregunto aquí en el
estudio manuel no solamente chávez es un
tipo un presidente personalista
tal vez autoritario también es
tecnócrata pero también es conservador
de hecho incluso días antes de digamos
de su posesión para revisar todos los
detalles de la posición fue al congreso
a la asamblea legislativa con la biblia
y de hecho el evento anterior o previo a
la posesión contó con las figuras
religión de la iglesia evangélica y la
iglesia católica de alguna forma esto ya
son señales de cuál es la agenda en
temas de derechos que tiene el
presidente chávez ahora hay que tener en
cuenta que no solamente el presidente es
quien decide quién toma las decisiones
en costa rica sino que también debe
contar con el congreso ahí es donde al
final de cuentas va a tener un reto
sobre avanzar en este tipo de agendas
tal vez pueda conseguir más apoyo en
otros digamos asuntos como los
económicos pero obviamente en los temas
morales va a ser un poco más difícil con
un congreso de amplia mayoría que
digamos está más relacionado con el tema
de la centroizquierda de asuntos
progresistas nada si le hago a usted la
misma pregunta que se puede esperar
respecto a estos temas
conociendo la conformación del congreso
pero sabiendo también el peso que ha
dado el presidente a este tipo de
revisión
la jefa de bancada del partido como se
llama el del presidente chávez en a
pilar cisneros ha sido muy clara en
cuáles van a ser los haberes no los
temas puntuales pero sí los temas
generales y ha sido muy clara en en
hacer hacer entender de que nunca tocar
temas que puedan llegar a ser éste
confrontativos así que yo lo creo
difícilmente que en un en un primer año
desde el partido social democrático
pueda presentar algún tema o algún
cambio por lo menos en este año
efectivamente por la conformación en que
está en este momento la asamblea
legislativa en costa rica
tal vez en esos temas puedan tener eco
en el partido nueva república sin
embargo el partido una república lo que
significa son siete votos verdad más los
diez que tiene en este momento el
partido social democrático ya no hacen
ni siquiera el mínimo necesario para que
este tema puede hacer puede ser
importante
obviamente a nivel de acuerdos políticos
a nivel de alianzas temáticas este el
las señales que sean y muy bien lo
mencionaba ahora a manuel en el sentido
de la biblia por ejemplo sea esos esos
esos temas obviamente marcan algunos
elementos la cercanía que en su momento
tuvo con la alianza evangélica la
cercanía que ha tenido con la
conferencia episcopal ver a don don don
rodrigo ha sido muy claro en establecer
que él es un presidente más de un corte
conservador verdad partiendo del hecho
de que costa rica sigue siendo un estado
confesional
entonces no esos esos pequeños el
elemento solamente marca muy
probablemente con cuáles van a ser estos
temas pero yo veo difícil muy difícil
que en el primer año estos tipos de
temáticas vayan a ponerse de acuerdo o
en presencia alguna agenda legislativa
cuando claramente y así me han hecho
saber el partido de liberación nacional
y el partido unidad social cristiana
el liberal progresista incluso de cuáles
son sus sus temas este planetario es
manal volvemos a marcar el tema del tema
de su empleo ven a crear este puente de
empleo en la reactivación económica la
parte científica ción de trámites que si
bien es cierto son temas importantes
pueden tener un más fácil consenso pero
hay que empezar en este momento a tener
este traspiés o problemas con temas que
sabemos que eventualmente se puedan
poner en agenda legislativa pero que va
a significar este un problema de crear
esos consensos que efectivamente son
necesarios para que se puedan ver
cambios en cualquier elemento de nuestra
legislación bueno pasó a hablar con
alejandro y le pregunto ahora en materia
ambiental costa rica busca que para 2050
ya no haya uso de combustibles fósiles
su cobertura forestal sobrepasa el 53
por ciento del territorio y ya de hecho
alcanzó un
99,98 por ciento de generación eléctrica
de fuentes renovables en esta nación se
firmó en 2018 el acuerdo de escazú
considerado el primer gran pacto de
latinoamérica y pionero en la protección
de los ambientalistas el presidente
chávez ya descartó que lo vaya a
ratificar dijo que todo lo que dice el
acuerdo está en la legislación
costarricense con excepción de una parte
que según él permitiría que cualquier
persona frene proyectos de inversión
privada con sólo denunciar que haya un
daño al medio ambiente esto puede ser
preocupante para el país y para la
región como interpretan esta negativa
del mandatario
la negativa del mandatario chávez
a la ratificación del acuerdo de escazú
se contextualiza en una negativa que no
viene únicamente de su partido ni de su
candidatura en su momento y ahora como
en su investidura de presidente sino que
ha habido numerosos grupos de la
sociedad costarricense
principalmente grupos de poder económico
como lo puede ser la unión de cámaras
del sector privado que es la principal
cámara empresarial en el país han
realizado una presión muy notoria en
contra de la firma en contra la
ratificación mejor dicho del acuerdo de
escazú en el pasado gobierno y en la
pasada asamblea legislativa esa presión
de este grupo empresarial
tuvo muchos réditos en bancas como los
del partido unidad social cristiana
incluso en determinados sectores del
partido liberación nacional
de cara precisamente a estas elecciones
también se pronunciaron en contra la
ratificación del acuerdo a esta azul
algo que hay que también mencionar en
materia ambiental es que por ejemplo el
ministro de ambiente designado nombrado
por el presidente rodrigo chávez
se han manifestado en contra de la
explotación petrolera en el país lo cual
es sin duda un rasgo relativamente
distintivo de costa rica sin embargo si
ha abierto la puerta para la explotación
de gas natural lo cual es visto con
sospecha por gran parte de los grupos
ambientalistas en el país entonces de
alguna manera podríamos señalar que el
presidente chávez estaría dispuesto a
implementar políticas públicas y
ambientalistas
sin embargo su límite sería la
rentabilidad es decir las políticas
ambientales serían implementadas hasta
que no intervengan con el buen rumbo a
los negocios por llamarlo de alguna
manera de ahí se explica la negativa de
suministro de ambiente a la explotación
petrolera precisamente porque argumentan
que en el corto mediano plazo será un
negocio que será sustituido por otras
formas de energía sin embargo como la
explotación de gas natural si puede ser
eventualmente rentable pues ahí
encontraríamos anuencia por por parte
del nuevo gobierno entonces si hubiera
que resumirlo de alguna forma sería que
la política ambiental del presidente
chávez se limitara hasta donde se
encuentre la línea la rentabilidad de
los negocios
bueno pues le pregunta manuel justamente
por esto que tan peligroso que tan
complicado puede ser para un país con
los estándares medioambientales que
tiene costa rica que estos negocios de
alguna manera choquen con las leyes y
con los avances que han logrado hasta
este momento pero lo que chávez va a
hacer es una agenda ambiental a la carta
es decir aquello que le parezca
conveniente para los negocios a que le
sea conveniente para el rumbo a la
economía y en eso coincido con alejandro
va a ser digamos lo que va a adoptar
el presidente chávez cuáles son los
riesgos ojo que de alguna forma costa
rica es una potencia medioambiental y al
ser una potencia medioambiental es una
potencia es un actor mejor que trata de
buscar el cumplimiento de transporte de
otros actores
en ese sentido perder esa digamos ese
protagonismo en américa latina como
defensores ambientales pues obviamente
va a ser un día más un trágico evento en
el sentido de que la agenda relacionada
con los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible pues seguramente se va a ver
debilitada en el continente entonces de
alguna forma esa selectividad en la
agenda medioambiental puede ser un
riesgo a futuro para que los demás
países de américa latina' continúen
cumpliendo los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible ok ahora paso a hablar con
danza y le pregunto en temas de lucha
contra la corrupción 2021 fue un año
particularmente difícil para costa rica
las autoridades taparon un caso
relacionado con proyectos de obras
públicas que involucró a dos poderosas
empresas que además son las principales
contratistas del estado y también se
conoció la presunta infiltración de
narcotraficantes en proyectos de en
zonas rurales tiene rodrigo chávez el
peso y un equipo que los rodea que sea
capaz de hacerle frente a esta
problemática que justamente fue una de
las banderas de su campaña la lucha
contra la corrupción
exactamente una una de las banderas que
sacaron rodrigo principalmente y creo
que lo ponen en la palestra de las
candidaturas pasando a ser emergente a
ser efectivamente actualmente nuestro
presidente es el tema de la corrupción
el tema de lo cual yo lo mencionaba
anteriormente que fue una unidad
adscrita en la casa a la casa
presidencial que hace procesos de manejo
de información de la ciudadanía que
efectivamente y en este momento tiene
prácticamente en el preámbulo al señor
ex presidente en un posible juicio
veremos ahora el proceso este judicial
ya no ya no bajo en investidura de la
presidencia sino como un ciudadano
normal por lo cual va a ser el trámite
que se le va a dar en estratos
judiciales a esta a esta situación y en
la posible participación que tuvo el
señor ex presidente este tocar los
alvarado en esta en este proceso pero
aparte de eso también existen modelos
mencionabas este problemas de posibles
actos de corrupción por fresas por
empresas privadas en la parte
constructiva y tenemos además para para
terminar de hacer de él el pastel un
poco más grande tenemos también posibles
este acto de corrupción en varias
figuras de alcaldías municipales en
costa rica entonces el tema de
corrupción y muchos se liga al objetivo
en un momento de campaña y lo hacía ver
el señor rodrigo chávez en su momento es
costa rica no es un país pobre es un
país que lo hemos supo que lo han
empobrecido en aquellas haciendo alusión
directa a estos actos de corrupción
ahora bien eso está claro verdad que una
una parte pasa por todo lo que es el
estrato judicial sea todo lo que es la
parte de cortes y la parte del 'vega
ligeramente pero también vienen otros
temas ligados a la toma de decisiones
con respecto a la parte ministerial y en
esto don rodrigo ha hecho una alusión
directa
la importancia de un proyecto que tuvo
cuando fue ministro de hacienda en el
anterior gobierno del carlos alvarado y
que según él alude que este proyecto de
prácticamente el que le cuesta su
cabeza ministerial verdad que era con la
colocación de scanners en los diferentes
puertos del país para empezar a habitar
tus cosas el tema de este el trasiego de
drogas y por otro lado el tema de la
evasión fiscal esto es esto tenga muy
probablemente llegue a ser uno de los
temas fundamentales en cómo se llama en
temas de la discusión y veremos a un
equipo de gobierno y me parece que en
esto cuando uno ve la forma en que uno
de lisboa ha coordinado empieza a
coordinar su web su proceso de
presidencia está claro que éste además
junto con con el tema de reactivación
económica basa en un tema importante
claro en el que tendrá o no
la capacidad de poder llevarlo a cabo me
parece que esto va a depender mucho de
las figuras que le está colocando en un
a nivel del ministerio de seguridad que
es el que engloba un poco esta temática
coloca a una persona que ya ha tenido
experiencia me dañé no es nuevo en el en
la parte de seguridad y que
probablemente va a facilitar venga así
como lo como se ha venido haciendo este
día y conseguir que su extradición el
tema de coordinación entre los
ministerios entrantes y los ministerios
salientes al govern es muy probablemente
veamos esto en uno de los muy
prontamente en temas de discusión de una
de acciones concretas discúlpenme que la
interrumpí ya se nos está terminando
aquí el tiempo y quiero hacer un cierre
muy breve preguntándoles a cada uno cuál
es la importancia de un mandatario como
chávez para la región inició con usted
manuel primero giro a la derecha giro
tecnócrata con un conservador en un país
en donde paradójicamente a nada en este
estudio está avances progresistas en
términos de los derechos de la mujer y
derechos sexuales y reproductivos y
mente también está la idea de es un
presidente que está digamos en aportas
de tratar de lograr un cambio en una las
democracias más estables porque porque
al final de cuentas la desigualdad y la
crisis económica pueden poner en riesgo
la democracia más estable y más
bicentenaria de nuestro continente bueno
pasó a preguntarle a alejandro la misma
pregunta la importancia de rodrigo
chávez para la región
y
coincido con manuel en lo que él señala
sobre ese giro hacia la derecha que
representa a nivel geopolítico en la
región si hay que mencionar por ejemplo
que costa rica ha sido siempre un país
muy cercano y aliado a la política
exterior de los eeuu eso pareciera ser
que cuando rodrigo chávez se va a
mantener incólume de la misma manera que
se mantuvo durante los 8 años de
gobierno del partido acción ciudadana y
los partidos tradicionales que
gobernaron previamente
si adquirirá mucha relevancia la
relación que pueda construir el
presidente chávez con la república
popular china que la cual es una
potencia que sabemos que ha incrementado
su presencia principalmente comercial en
la región y en campaña escuchamos y
ahora también como presidente electo en
numerosas intervenciones de don rodrigo
en esa dirección entonces a nivel
de política regional pues estas son las
claves por las cuales pasaría la
interpretación del gobierno de don
rodrigo bueno pues a nosotros se nos
acaba el tiempo aquí en france 24 por
ello quiero agradecerle a nuestros
invitados tanto en costa rica como aquí
en bogotá manuel gonzález magíster en
ciencia política nancy hernández
politóloga y alejandro molina politólogo
que nos acompañaron en este especial
también a nuestra corresponsal cindy
regidor que también estuvo en san jose
rodrigo chávez ya es el nuevo presidente
de costa rica después de esta ceremonia
de investidura a ustedes muchas gracias
por su sintonía por habernos acompañado
continúen en france24 que hay más